[Music]
you made it weird with pete holmes
what's happening weirdos this is it this
is uh video episode number two we're so
excited to be joining you obviously uh
audio for those of you listening the
original way i'll call it the original
way but for those of you joining us on
youtube this is only our second video
episode and i'm so excited that it's
this one it's jon hamm
you know jon hamm from top gun maverick
jeez louise katie jon hamm was right
next to us
and uh
we also have chris redd from snl and
matteo lane who is incredible and has
his own standalone episode coming up
very very soon little did i know but
chris and mateo are very dear friends so
do not make the mistake of of uh
flipping off flipping off
jumping off turning it off after ham
because it goes nuts when the two of
them are on stage together it's one of
the funniest things that's ever happened
i loved this episode and of course sweet
lady val is here co-hosting so i am
super super super super
excited for this one i'm so glad you
guys are here only a couple things to
plug up top june 11th is my only
stand-up date right now go to
largodashla.com if you'd like to come to
pete holmes living at largo it's always
amazing the last couple we had dimitri
martin rory scoville
amy schumer mullany but regardless of
who's there it's always always always me
and it's always always always incredible
and val is there too and it's always so
fun and if you like this show why not
try a pete's pick because it's video
look i have them i have them for the
camera this is ritual
synthiotic
[Laughter]
i didn't want to say it wrong
ritual synbiotic plus this is my
probiotic that i take every morning i'm
super super super into gut health your
stomach is basically like a second brain
and it needs stuff that it's not getting
in the food the way food is made these
days so you need to supplement i also
take rituals multivitamin which i swear
by i went to my doctor recently and they
were like your vitamins are off the
charts that is not easy for me to do as
a mostly vegan so i love their
multivitamin and i love synbiotic plus
it is a three in one with clinically
studied prebiotics
probiotics and a postbiotic to support a
balanced gut microbiome it's single
nested in a minty capsule that means
it's a pleasure to take it has a minty
flavor uh for simple streamlined gut
support it is designed to thrive with a
delayed release capsule designed to help
reach the colon that means it's not
breaking down in the stomach it waits
until it gets into your colon which is
the ideal place for prebiotics and
probiotics to survive and grow and no
refrigeration are needed in fact a lot
of the ones you see in the grow in the
grocery store the reason they're
refrigerators because they're so fragile
they're probably not gonna make it home
these are designed with moisture
controlled bottle technology to protect
the probiotic strains and handle life in
your cupboard with absolutely no problem
synbiotic and ritual are here to
celebrate not hide your insides there's
no shame in your gut game that's why
ritual is offering weirdos 10 off during
your first three months visit ritual.com
weird to start ritual or add symbiotic
plus to your subscription today like i
did val steals mine we've just added two
bottles to my monthly supply because she
loves it so much too sure you support
the show go to ritual.com
weird and let's talk about clothes let's
talk about clothes in a different way
let's talk about the plastic problem
plastic is a huge global crisis on this
planet we call earth if it's not piling
up in a landfill it's incinerated and
driving up greenhouse gases or broken
down into micro plastics that end up in
the oceans and up in our drinking water
and our food chains so you probably know
that and you're probably careful about
your plastic consumption but you're
probably not overlooking the plastics
from synthetic materials that are hiding
in our closets that are in our clothes
not this clothes not these clothes this
is made by everlane baby everlane is
here to help this issue and make
fantastic clothes this is this is my
everlane sweater it is my favorite
sweater it is the sweater that val
requests the most the most when we go on
dates everlane has made it 90 of the way
to having no new plastics in their
entire apparel footwear and packaging
supply chain ninety percent the way
there no plastics that's incredible to
combat the last ten percent that
currently doesn't have quality
alternatives they've created the nest
collective a fellowship program to boost
innovation for ending new plastics in
the fashion industry i love everlane's
commitment to ethical factories it's
clothing that you can feel good about
buying and a company you can feel good
about supporting and their new their no
new plastic effort so far has been
incredible 100
of their shipping packaging is made from
either 100 recycled plastic or fsc
certified paper
95 of the apparel materials containing
polyester and nylon are made from
certified recycled fibers and more than
one million pounds of nylon and nine
million plastic bottles have been
recycled by this wonderful company they
also just happened to make some of the
best looking best fitting best feeling
clothing that i've ever owned in my life
but i absolutely love how transparent
and upfront they are and how ethical
they are as a company so be a part of
the movement for more sustainable
clothing and frankly look pretty
freaking great while you do it go to
everlane.com slash weird and sign up for
10 off your first order that's 10 off
your first order when you go to
everlane.com
weird and sign
up
all right that's it
i paused there big time
guys i'm so excited for you to see this
live episode thank you to all the
weirdos who came out in person and i
really really enjoy that you guys are
here what am i not an english-speaking
person i really really enjoy that you
guys are the ones that are here enjoy
jon hamm enjoy chris redd matteo lane
sweet lady val
get into it
[Music]
in my opinion
do your best blossom dance right now i
don't have a baggy enough sweater yeah
we can't do it that was we clearly
couldn't do john b from pete
joe oh
valerie whoa there it is all right this
is not cool we did not enter cool this
was not what isn't cool like i feel like
we were just like very awkward with our
bodies and then i did like no i know the
impression
it's not you made it composed baby doll
oh that's true it's not you you made it
weird that's right we were expecting an
applause there or no okay
if i wanted that i'd go let's have a joe
rogan experience and then we just no eat
venison shot with a bow
who who brought the bow venison jerky
nobody
good to be here
uh where they shot the mask question
mark
[Music]
i think this is where cameron diaz sang
and he was like somebody stopped me yeah
i got greedy i went for two mask laughs
mm-hmm you're like you guys are like
give me one uh-huh
wow thanks for keeping us on it's good
for you max we just had it
everyone else you'll be fine yeah
wow that was a real frequency you guys
all just admitted
we were like don't make us think about
it
play the blossom theme again please we
need a palette cleanser
just kidding who knows the first line of
the blossom theme
joke's on you it's for 100k
so you're going to drive home and be
like don't know about the future that's
anybody's guess
i think the only thing people know from
the blossom theme is the word
opinionation
that's correct yeah can we all say happy
uh valentine's day to valerie just
kidding happy mother's day to valerie
everybody
and to all the all the moms here
thank you i mean is there anything more
loaded
or nuanced than mothers like it feels
like a oh yeah it's like a tone deaf
kind of thing we're like yeah yeah like
everybody has a complicated relationship
with their mother or a complicated
relationship with being a mother or with
like like not being a mother it's too
it's too complicated why are we
completely agree completely like it's
just i mean obviously it's like a
greeting card thing right they yes they
were like you can
buy this card and give it to your mother
being like i wish i meant this
oh
too sad that was a great riff you said i
wish i meant this yeah really hard to
hear i'm sorry i brought it down
happy mother's day to me too and i just
took it dark i don't know about the
future
that's anybody's guess is this voice
okay okay how's everybody doing
i'm not getting canceled for doing a
great impression of the blossom theme
song
oh my god
it didn't hurt it's a youtube clip
i really hope somebody was filming that
and they were there's cameras
we'll make it into a gif i'm not getting
cancelled yeah and then
yeah there you go thank you very much
i will sell it as an nft
still don't know what an nft is anybody
he already buy it
it's like diving to like so everybody
thinks they could be the one to teach me
how to dive and i've never been able to
learn and it means oh dive off a board
yeah and everybody thinks that they can
be the one to teach me an nft and i
can't retain it i just i guess i just
don't care no you shouldn't care i
wouldn't be interested in you as a
partner if you cared yeah it's like i
really do classify like nft uh bitcoin
still are those the same who knows uh
all with like wim hof and cold plunging
like this is the same type of person
shots fired he's into those things and
i'm married to him and we just don't
talk about those things i don't know how
i feel about the fun mother's day
it's not your day it's my day to say
what i really feel and that's right it's
your day
nfts are for those of us who are tired
of tokens getting funged all the time
look he's gotta go early we're gonna
bring him right out are you ready for
[__] john hamm goddamn
[Music]
you made it weird
you made it weird there's no music you
made it weird john
hamm
you made it weird
you made it weird john hamm
you made it weird you made it weird
john
hamm oh
there you go
i would like you to look at this chair
oh i looked at it okay
it's
it's gone stings
yeah like it's not a bit no it it really
it there's jizz
[Applause]
that that is
like a bird came in here and came all
over the chair
that's as likely as an owl killing
kathleen peterson have a seat i was just
gonna make oh
you knew i was gonna say that i was
gonna say that joke also did you like
have the experience i had which is i
didn't even know there were people up in
the balcony until jon hamm walked out
and then a whole crew
yeah those are the ham fans
they got ham price tickets that's half
price
just bring any slice of ham to any show
that i'm appearing on you getting free
pam makes everything better ham is
delicious and it makes everything better
and you're welcome yeah that's right
john john hamm port
port port pit
[Laughter]
i want to say up top i'm sorry for
asking you to sit in jizz
um i'm also seated in jizz well good i
mean if we're all doing it yeah and by
the way don't look at your seats
yeah this is like a reverse it's the top
of the seat horrible oprah everybody got
jizz tonight exactly and you get to see
you
you get to sit in jail oh no dirty oprah
oh dirty oprah
here's my here's my first question what
if that was her first like take on being
oprah
her first what just like like a weird
like colin sleazy friends show like it
was dirty oprah and it didn't really hit
and people were like i get what you're
going for but this is probably not what
you should be doing
let's flip the whole script and be like
super pleasant
all right yes
people forget that oprah started as like
a shock
like you want to meet dr phil you want
to see his balls hey
no no i'm asking
uh take it as you will have you done
oprah
have you been on oprah
wait
it's not getting any less dirty let me
hold on have you been on top of oprah
i figure that's exactly what you meant
and no i have not yet i haven't had the
pleasure now no yes that's steadman man
that's what you want that's a no ham
zone
for real
maybe gail listen
that's that's a good question do you
like being jon hamm is it fun i think a
lot of people would be like i'd love to
be john hamm or are there times when
you're like [__] i wish i could hang up
my head somewhere and just be uh one of
these guys angry
like i pick one of you just like for
being not john him like this piece of
[__]
look at this piece of [__] ain't no one
clamoring
no selfies i'm sorry what's your name
jason you're the king james center mason
which one was it because or is it port
jason jason he pulled down the mask he
wanted that full hand absolutely
yeah
he wanted unprotected ham on ham gaze
um but for real do you ever go like [__]
it would be more convenient to not be
john hammond right now no it's it is you
know not for nothing it was like work i
worked very hard to get where i am in my
career in life and everything i feel
very lucky certainly that i've found
success much later than most yeah uh and
i also am very like someone say you
haven't found it yet but someone
i'm still mad about the port thing but
keep going
but let me ask you that here here's
another one here have some ibm when you
walk into a party everyone knows uh they
like probably people want a piece of
that sweet sweet ham right yeah maybe
i'm not sure you know i haven't really
had that that experience so much i
mostly go to you know parties with
people i know so it's a yeah i don't
really go to like uh uh that's not a
party that's a soiree for sure i'm
talking about like you walk into you
rust again
which you can do now again which you can
do i think they were open the whole
thing for sure they were like i don't
know just go on the side door
doesn't know it hits the front and
bounces off they'll pull on the side
you'll be fine there's much worse in
that bar than copenhagen
these chairs are clean compared to
what's on
on offer you can get covered 20 at years
again right now
i know a guy you can get covered like
15.
i have like vintages yeah oh my god your
covet uh sommelier comes up he's like
tell me what you want i'll breathe it
right on you i'm feeling nostalgic could
i have coveted 21.
i'm going to say it to you i i miss code
15. i'll say it
it was a different time
trump wasn't president yet there was
like a whole difference it's you know it
felt like a more
more fun way to you know yeah lose your
breath i judge history
lose your breath i die it was cute it
was you oh lose your breath
uh from memory how much of john's ham
jon hamm can you remember
very little uh i remember i remember
doing that sketch and thinking like well
this is never going to make it on the
air
but somebody in the prop department
built a toilet paper roll out of ham
that has a piece of ham that rolls off
of it so i was like well maybe i can
keep it
did you keep it i did not no it
certainly wouldn't keep
[Laughter]
you can't keep that you can't even
maintain it in your possession
you can have it but you cannot believe
by the end of the after party it's
probably you probably don't yeah it's
that weird green shimmery you know oh
yeah no everybody knows no no disrespect
to your namesake but ham is one of the
wetter slimy it is a wet it's a wet meat
yeah like would you rather be john
turkey that's a fair question maybe a
salami like a cured
yeah
mommy yeah a prosciutto maybe
this means ham
when you walk around the streets of rome
as i'm assuming you do this is what i do
all the time and people scream hey
exactly what happened you ever [__] all
pro like that sort of thing
not now but like dirty oprah hey
and then they
get on the bus off they go they know the
bit they've listened to this podcast
when she was directed at the beginning
dr phil's bomb like calling sleazy
friends the cable access no one
remembers is this voice okay
i don't know
much longer
latecomer joke's on you ham was first oh
don't worry you're so cute no no welcome
welcome welcome welcome so john's
handling the jeans on your chair it's uh
we didn't do it they were there
yeah
we were doing the whole jizz thing it's
fine
you missed our
it's like an appetite it comes back he
never you know doesn't stay hidden for
long
god
it's so great to be here at the end of
both of our careers
don't know about the future it's
anybody's guess joey lawrence comes off
and says whoa you can't oh you can't
keep italian you can't even do me
[Laughter]
that's where this is headed guys we
won't even be able to do joe joey
lawrence
i can't even go to sarah lawrence or
of arabia
who would you be starstruck to see
because joey lawrence that's up there
for me
yeah
with the hair we're currently joey
lawrence in the 80s yeah 80s lawrence
yes so it's time travel um i mean i
don't know like there there's a couple
like 80s
uh you know and we remember no one's
gonna remember boy this is so damn
people will clap but they will clap you
will clap you will clap
you get a clap
there was a show that i'm pretty sure
was a spin-off of different strokes
which you also can't say anymore um but
called hello because it's spelled so
that you have to say it in a way it's
like yeah nope you don't look at it and
you're like oh yeah uh that's not for me
to say it's different
stroke i love the tv show different
strokes i enjoyed it very much listen to
how they're nervous for their careers
when the they don't want to be on the
record for laughing at a pretty
when the younger character says what are
you talking about
[Laughter]
and i was like i don't know what is he
talking about
what what did the gooch really do
i had two daughters i forget what his
job was it was it was kind of like the
the other one which was uh ted knight
which is where he played a cartoonist
which was too close for comfort maybe
yes okay those people are who you want
to co-sign on a loan for your house
like anyone they are old enough they're
old enough these natives if they're
still coming to shows and rocking and
getting these references they have a lot
of money but there was
they're doing just fine
they did an uber here but there was like
a girl that my like 12 year old self had
a massive crush on that became like a
real housewives oh like i don't know if
i ever met her but that would have been
like a real like whoa like you mean the
tv show or she's just a housewife for
real
she really became a housewife and then
and then got on the show
of her experience i mean they are
[Laughter]
we are triple cancelled for this and i'm
loving it
um i feel like we're roman warriors in
the movie 300 and i'm like i'm glad to
go down by your side that's that's very
kind of you yeah uh we're both wearing
all of the clothes
here's a question shoot you're i mean
this you're very you're like you're kind
of like a masculine symbol like people
are like ah jon hamm
there's a man so i'd like i'd love to
know
do you do you dance like will you dance
dance for sure yeah thank you yes of
course but have you noticed like macho
guys in movies never dance uh don draper
didn't dance do you damn don draper did
dance how dare you when did he dance he
danced i think he only really's
daughter's funeral
at sally draper's funeral
right on the grave oh my god
oh follow-up question about your
daughter your daughter's initials are
sbd was it hard to say that without
laughing s
spd spd sbd sally draper
but deadly
yes we all clocked that very early
it was pretty great
[Laughter]
but you'll dance for sure okay i mean of
course like it's it's it's fun i think i
don't know yeah it's like what's the
other thing dan's like no one's watching
but also prove it prove it yeah there's
one guy that's like i don't believe it
shake it for me
well val and i were talking about my
chairs covered in jail
we need a fresh coat
oh no
told you was coming back told him jizz
always comes back
she's on the rocks well we watched uh
jack reacher and we were like why do
tough guys never did i know yeah look
mad men's been off for six years we have
to do something we have to only watch
things i'm in but coming off of jizz and
then using the first two syllables her
and jack and jack jack jack reader jack
reacher
were you like near it were you like like
around it were your jack reach around
jack
did you jack reacher around jack reach
around the house i don't know that's
like when you watch it on your laptop
and you just get it yeah when you when
you watch it i was watching exactly in
the shower
i was watching jack reach around jack
reach around the house that's what i now
get
fine well we were like why don't tough
guys dance and val was like i think it's
because men want to like be masculine we
affect reality and being vulnerable to
music you have to like let it let it
view and let it run the show i think i
think travolta changed the game not only
in uh saturday night fever but also in
uh pulp fiction that's true yeah and
that was pretty cool he was pretty cool
he's tough guy he was like doing the
thing and uh yeah
the twist i mean that was that was when
we thought was like never coming back
but yeah you know brad pitt's not
dancing and once upon a time in
hollywood right you know what i mean
with that attitude
get him let's bring him out brad come on
brad come on in
prove it
[Laughter]
we hear another level of a balcony
applied oh my god yeah they added a
level we didn't know there was a second
balcony until brad pitt came out
that's not a cool name brad pitt
i'm gonna be a movie star my name's brad
pitt it's like all right [__] dude
you're talking to a person named john
hance
[Laughter]
i'll take pit any day
oh my god ham pit have you met brad pitt
have you met brad pitt yes i have yes
that that is a person that is uh i don't
care who you are you are sort of struck
in a star-strucky way or just like oh
lord this is happening yeah he's from my
home state of missouri he's from a
different part of it hey right on the
show me state so uh yeah
show me you damn show me you can dance
uh
that was that was harris truman's famous
thing i could get in here and the book
stops here and show me
oh so you think you can dance or show me
that was the full title of that that was
yeah so you think you could dance i was
having guys
and you are welcome um
but no he's he's from a very small town
my my fam is a very small town although
i grew up in st louis but yeah we we've
met on several locations it is a
it is a full-on movie star experience
yeah were they all in like party
hollywood atmospheres they were in like
sort of more of a low-key uh situation
you're always brought to like a basement
restaurant
i mean
candles i have had that experience but
not with with brad pitt but john
travolta on several occasions but uh it
was like mr travolta would like to talk
to you
wait you were brought into a candlelight
and he's sat at a table it looks like
the last supper there's like 15 people
and he's like hey john i heard you were
here's at the super bowl or something
you're like what is going on
this is crazy
i bring all my friends and we fly i fly
them up and we go to the super bowl over
here isn't that fun you're like it's fun
it's great i don't i don't know how to
get out of this conversation at all
except say thank you and you look great
and i'm gonna
have a good time go team then
it's in the it's in the super bowl
he flies his friends to say he's like
he's a pilot he's a he's a he has a 737
or something so he like packs it up
yeah he's a fair how do you talk to
somebody that also flies planes
i can't be as exciting as a plane
[Laughter]
you can't
alright karaoke will you sing karaoke
what's your song i usually pick a prince
song because it's unexpected yeah and i
know a lot of the words already oh and
uh yeah you don't want to be reading
breaking out the glasses yeah and
because yeah i can't really see anymore
like i don't know yeah it's a bts yeah
dynamite oh
classic now well that's a more sensible
car he should have been driving that the
entire time i could put people in the
back seat prince you said he filmed some
of purple rain here
at this uh
right here i think we're sitting in his
juice right now
oh we're sitting here
called the bird so we know he left his
mark
thank you
actually
i like that we have a mutual
acquaintance who told me that did you go
to one of his last concerts i went to
his last school you went to his last
prince's last prince's last show in
atlanta georgia at the fox theater very
famous old
venue
and it was amazing it was a it was a sh
the tour was called piano and a
microphone and it was a piano and a
microphone he played
like 40 songs kind of back to back on
the piano whoa and it was like amazing
it was and it was in atlanta the place
was packed and heaving and people
brought their own tambourines it was
like it was the church it was like going
to church it was amazing
uh did he ever stop and go it's piano
and microphone put that [__]
tambourine away
i don't recall seeing on the sign piano
microphone and some [__] brought
tambourines
that's what i would have done if i was
that is not what he did
he would he would do a thing
he realized his catalog is hundreds and
hundreds upon hundreds of songs for
decades yeah and uh he would start
something that the whole crowd would
immediately from the first like name
that tune chord recognize
and then
stop and kind of look and with a deep
voice just go no you're ready y'all
aren't ready for that yet
oh my god and then he would do like a
deep cut from the black album wow and
like it was just like oh my god like
it's amazing yeah it's getting humid in
here and you're just telling the story
yeah
what a talent that's because of never
mind there's there's some other um
fluids on this chair
here we go there's a viable embryo on
this chair now because of that story
well that's gonna be that's gonna
present a problem yeah
were you full ham at that point did you
get out that was in that was in i was on
he knows what i meant i knew it just
answered were you for him oh yeah it's
for him
oh yeah yeah did you get to meet prince
no he was he left the show and like
whisked away and got on a plane and that
was it and yeah yeah the rest is history
but that was during uh when we were
shooting baby driver so that was 2016.
oh wow did you have the haircut did i
have the haircut yes baby haircut i had
a baby haircut the baby haircut the baby
the baby him
maybe him little baby him here's other
questions
i'm some guy
i just want to know do you do requests
because you're such a lovely guy i
really mean that i just i i was for once
like if somebody comes up and goes will
you do my voicemail greeting and they're
really nice about it will you do it i
have certainly done that i i yeah uh
it's it's it's like yeah it's lovely i
remember uh you are just
yeah what a man yeah he saw salted the
earth guys that was very salty
you're incredibly salt of the earth
you're you're a ham and egger that's
what you are
and i love it it's really great okay you
do voicemails what do you say if you do
that
whatever they
i will do it uh the detective from the
town thank you very much adam frawley
how dare you for not having his name
immediately on your i don't think his
name is said in that movie adam might
not be i don't think you know
that's only because this is how great
boston is
i'm ostensibly the hero of that film
because
law enforcement everyone in boston hates
me yeah
ben ben put one over on you leaving that
[__] thing on your car
idiot
federal europe investigate keeping
people safe
in florida with a beard
sitting on a beach where are you in an
office
on tremont street
for ollie
you didn't even do the accent i'm not
from boston in the movie sir yeah you
are
i
not dance no
[Laughter]
show us
yeah no boston
mullany said it bets he was like it's
the only
city that has all these movies where
it's like getting out like it's the
point it's like can you leave can you
leave without being murdered in other
movies there's problems in movies about
boston boston is the problem
murder
that's not very good that actually made
our wedding vows do you remember yeah
the movie the town was in our wedding
vows
i promised to watch
uh any movie about getting out of boston
or where any other white man succeeds
with him
yeah that's all i thought you were gonna
say like that after you got married
you're like we are now the priest was
gonna say you are now part of the not
[__] around crew
yeah because that's no [__] around
things about to go both ways
all right that would have been cooler
watch the movie and laugh later um
would you do rupaul's drag race
would i do it yeah
i'm pretty sure i'm not no you are they
they've asked me to do it so they'd ask
cam to do it once again
they've asked you to do it
[Laughter]
but uh i would do it yeah it's amazing i
mean uh sure like it's the those kinds
of things are this is what we why we do
what we do it's like to have fun like
that seems like a really fun
like experience and then to see all the
incredible work that goes into all this
stuff is is inspiring i don't know i
would i would do it just to yeah look
how terrible i am i got it
sure yeah i i'm really
yeah i know
it's a point of contention still so
scared of my dad
like
i'm terrified of my dad of course i'd
love to do it bring him on the show
oh my god what the [__] is going on here
get those cantaloupes out of your shirt
you have a natural breast let the people
see it
dad i will say the eye makeup is
tasteful
you can see it just into one part of it
i like when you do the swoopy eye i'll
say a cat eye looks great on you peter
[Laughter]
you never could drew a girl a mustache
so don't worry about it
my parents today
that's generous my dad can't hear [__]
so
he comes on and goes
on and i'm like hey flapjacks
all the gym gyms with the sally bell and
then i'll go like that and he'll be like
that's great that's great
and that sounds mean but like he didn't
listen to me for so long
it's really nice but it's better than
having an actual conversation that won't
be heard i think there you go yeah thank
you
thank you that's exactly what it is yeah
it hurts when you're like well pop a
lot's been going on this week and he
goes like yeah they're a good team
your heart just shatters he does that
with our daughter like our daughter is
three and a half and never pays out but
for some reason always when she's
facetiming with him she'll be like i
love you grumpy that's what she calls
him and he'll be like
leela what are you doing you go to
school and it's like she's just like she
just gave you the results she would
never say that to us did you hear that
he doesn't hear it
it's a shame
it's a 45 minute appointment at the ear
doctor
and he's like yeah what could i be
missing what's wrong
i'm sorry i wasn't i wasn't done letting
out comedic rage
[Laughter]
fresh fresh better out there yeah better
out than in like jizz like yeah
yeah
yeah you brought it back
[Laughter]
you made it weird
pardon the interruption weirdos this
episode of you made it weird is brought
to us by our friends at lollipop that's
right it's lollipop not ollie pop stop
saying ollie pop you sound like you
sound dumb
it's lollipop a new kind of soda i am
holding my favorite flavor which was one
of their newer flavors classic grape you
know i think the last time i had had a
grape soda was probably in junior high
at a bowling alley when emily bravo
didn't want a sip of it because she
didn't like grape what's wrong with you
emily bravo
i like grape and lollipop makes an
incredible incredible classic grape soda
in fact they make wonderful wonderful
healthier soda alternatives it's not a
diet soda it is a better soda i'm
talking vintage cola classic root beer
orange squeeze cherry vanilla strawberry
vanilla probably my second favorite they
make classic grape obviously we talked
about it tropical punch new
tropical punch get into it you know what
one that tastes like and banana cream
and orange cream these are some dope
ass flavors lollipop is a new kind of
soda it tastes like the sodas we grew up
with but unlike those sodas that are
full of sugar corn syrup and artificial
in ingredients like aspartame lollipop
is made with natural ingredients that
are actually good for you it's the
fastest growing functional beverage
brand in america they use functional
ingredients and combine the benefits of
prebiotics plant fiber and botanicals to
support your microbiome and benefit
digestive health 90 percent of americans
consume more than the usda's daily
recommended added sugar intake which is
30 grams
sweetened beverages like soda are the
leading source of added sugar in the
american diet lollipop is much much much
lower in sugar than conventional sodas
with only two to five grams of sugar
from natural sources and no added sugar
their vintage cola for example has two
grams of sugar compare that to coca-cola
which has 39
and it tastes
fantastic it is an incredible drink we
go through them so fast in our house
it's non-gmo it's vegan it's paleo it's
keto friendly with less than eight grams
net carbs per can they're so confident
that you will love their products they
offer a hundred percent money-back
guarantee for orders placed through
their website and we have a special deal
for weirdos receive 20 off plus free
shipping on your order i recommend
trying the variety pack that's a great
way to check out all the delicious
flavors go to drink olliepop.com weird
or use code weird at checkout to claim
this deal that's d-r-i-n-k-o-l
dot com slash weird they can also be
found in over 6 000 stores across the
country including kroger whole foods
sprouts and wegmans but show your
support of this show get it at all drink
dot com slash weird this podcast is
sponsored by better help as you know we
are big fans on the show of talk therapy
as you know life is full of twists and
turns stress changes grief moments of
growth and moments where we all feel
like we're taking a few steps back and
it's important to show up for yourself
through all the struggles that life can
bring better help online therapy is here
for the twists and the turns and will
assess your needs and can help you and
can help match you sorry with your own
licensed professional therapist in less
than 48 hours it's not a crisis line
it's not self-help it's professional
therapy done securely online and the
service is available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
therapist you can schedule weekly video
or phone sessions so you don't even have
to sit in an uncomfortable waiting room
as with traditional therapy i can attest
to that it's always a little bit strange
in a waiting room betterhelp is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change therapists if needed
that's a lot of awkwardness avoided
right there it's also more affordable
than traditional offline therapy and
financial aid is available better help
is a great way to show up for yourself
and invest in your well-being because
well you deserve some inner peace so
visit their website and read their
testimonials that are posted daily go to
betterhelp.com reviews and visit
betterhelp.com
weirdo that's help h-e-l-p not health
better help
betterhelp.com
weirdo and join the over 2 million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional in fact so many
people have been using better help
they're even recruiting additional
therapists in all 50 states so for
weirdos get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
[Music]
weirdo thank you betterhelp for
sponsoring this episode
you made it weird thank you john have
you ever almost died
i have had a gun pulled on me once by
someone i did not a gun or a gun knife
because we need to know
which can we talk about that for one
second because i'm very confused as why
why you would have a knife
in the shape of a gun
it should like what it do is the guy
supposed to put his hands up and then
you're like haha now i can get you in
your tummy
you opened up for me the more sensible
thing would be a knife that shoots
bullets
no one's expecting that you've got a
knife and they're like come on
[Laughter]
so your last words are like what are you
gonna do with a knife give me give me
way far away
well he didn't want to bring a knife to
a gunfight and he didn't know which kind
of fight it was exciting he wanted to be
on
both yeah how slick was the floor it
looked like it happened on ice
how long was that run-up i've been to
the hollywood bowl there yeah
there's some space between the wings and
uh downstage center
term
[Laughter]
so you had a gun pulled on you yes it
was in new orleans uh louisiana and i
wisely uh
back up back up back up many many moons
ago where are you
in the french quarter and you're leaving
leaving some bar and attempting to walk
back to the hotel uh yeah you're alone
yeah smart because i'm 25 and nothing
bad has ever happened to me because i'm
uh white and yeah smart and was raised
with a tremendous amount of privilege um
edit that out ham on the run
so you're walking alone and uh
you know it's there's there's good
blocks and bad blocks and good
neighborhoods and bad numbers in new
orleans and they're very you can take
the wrong terms it's a pre-iphone era
pre
well i followed this way to go here and
a pretty uber and a pretty thing i was
like what's two blocks i can walk it and
i just remember getting i could see my
hotel and i turned to the thing and i go
to the city and the person is coming up
to me and how you doing whatever
and uh they're always nice outside there
was a all of a sudden it was a gun and i
was like oh that's a that's a gun
and i put my hands up and i took
everything out of my pockets i put it on
the ground and i was like that is all
whatever you want out of that is yours
and i will i'm gonna go right over there
and uh take it leave it do whatever you
want uh just don't shoot me and the guy
was like okay
[Laughter]
i love that you're setting the terms
what if he just wanted to show you his
cool gun oh my god man
i'm not a criminal you've been waiting a
long time there's a waiting period
and you're like okay there you go
you're profiling
there's not a lot of you know there's
there's
everything happens at once and it seems
like in slow motion and it seems like
it's mass motion and all of the blood
runs all of the places and the sweat
pours out of you and then as soon as
it's sort of over
you have this kind of hyperventilating
moment but yeah so to to answer your
question that i i guess i almost died
yeah no that's a fantastic answer and
i'm going to say it it's a fantastic
question
yes to both how about anything ever
happened to you that you can't explain
i'm broadening the question have you
ever gone to a psychic that knew
something really personal about you have
you ever seen it no but i will tell this
story and i think it's kind of cool um i
used to have kind of and i still have
them but like these dreams that become
very very very real very uh
uh
almost three-dimensional but like almost
like a waking dream like you you feel
like you're very much in the dream you
know it's a dream because of attendance
of the dream and um but you're also like
i'm i'm making choices i'm sitting down
i'm talking
and it happens at like sort of
inflection points in my life so when i
first like went to college um i had a
dream and my mother who died when i was
very young
appeared in the dream and said you're
going to be okay
it's a college is very
it's a very big place it's a new place
but you're going to be okay
and i remember waking up and i was fully
like
sob weeping
and like i left the next day for college
and i was relatively okay uh and then
the day before i moved to california
from st louis i was getting ready to
leave i was sleeping in my on my
friend's couch
my car was packed up i had all 150 and a
discover card uh added to my game where
we're a mastercard massacre sorry and a
discover card a capital one mastercard
what's in my wallet that
what's in my wallet discover card deal
with that deal sorry
company that didn't exist in 1995
uh
and my in the ensuing period my uh
father had passed away as did my
father's mother my grandmother who i
lived with for many years and all three
of them showed up that night in the
dream
and said you're gonna be okay and i woke
up again this like heaving sobbing to
where i like woke my friend up i was
like dude are you okay i was like uh
yeah i'm fine i just i just i'll be okay
i think because my mommy told me i'm
going to be okay and my daddy
my granny
leave me alone
um and i got my car the next day and i
was okay wow
i just want to point out we don't do a
pre-interview so that is like the best
like off the cuff something i can't
explain i mean i'm a bit of a lucid
dreamer and then you break off into it
that was incredible your pure show
business you spread on smooth and it was
kind of mother's day themed it was on
theme oh it is mother's day
here's to you abraham
yeah absolutely any any lucid dreams
lately um no i haven't had one in a in a
while um i might have i feel like i
might have had one the day before we
started shooting mad men but i will tell
this
awful story i remember waking up on the
day we had to shoot madman and i had
auditioned for the show eight times i
had worked on every piece of the script
with the director and the writer and
everybody and i just i knew that
backwards and forwards and up and down
and i remember looking at myself
going like okay get some sleep and of
course i couldn't sleep and it's two in
the morning i have to be there at five
at silver cup studios and what are we
gonna do and i get there in the van and
the guy pulls up and they're like what's
going on there's a dead body in the
parking lot
whoa
covered in a sheet
and they said cheese covered in cheese
sorry i'm hungry uh okay
shredded cheese shredded cheese guys
don't back off you're shredded like you
like you would say no it was a mixture
it was a blend there was a blend of
shredded cheese fiesta cheese fiesta
it's a fiesta cheese
uh no it was covered in a sheet and uh
and there was one of those little nypd
like three wheel one man
scooter deals with with a roof and doors
oh yeah well guarding it
and we kind of pulled up next like is
everything okay like yeah somebody uh
jumped off the bridge
where like if you know if you know
silver cup there's like the 59th street
bridge or whatever you come right over
there and it literally goes over the
thing and it turns out he hadn't jumped
he fell out of a moving car that
was like a jeep or something they
finally figured this out and like the
guy did a twist
or a turn or an evasive maneuver of some
sort and the dude like went flying and
and landed and they yeah it didn't work
out for him that is the real first day
of shooting and that was it was there
all day like we kept like finishing
shooting a thing i mean like is the
thing it's still there okay
somebody gonna like dude like get that
like who do you who you gonna call
valerie that was incredible matt winer
was looking out the window and was like
i have an idea
that was the riff of the [__] country
wow and because it involved death that
happened to someone you don't know a
long time ago most of you were like
we'll sit out on expressing joy
just in case that dude comes back to
bite us in the ass
because that was incredible i was
very very well done i've never been more
proud of you
um ham we've taken so much of your time
real speed round ready uh oh
what's your favorite cheap food you just
wrapped shop gun can't wait to see it
what are you chowing down what's my
favorite what cheat cheap food don't pay
a corpse with mexican cheese on it well
no i'm doing it because i know you don't
like it but i will say i will say
anything mexican food i will go towards
a taco or or a burrito or a tamale of
some sort i'm a big fan all right all
right correct that is not nachos calm
down over said that let me let me list
my food you list yours when you're up
here
um
we by the way nacho's the worst mexican
food because i'm sorry this is the speed
run but you know what you brought it up
[Laughter]
you get one decent nacho out of a plate
of nachos oh my god and then it's all
over the place yeah bear chips
soggy mess you might as well eat it with
a fork it might as well be called
something completely different the one
good nacho
which is you are correct delicious but
the plate
is then ruined anyway i
literally that took my breath away
because it's been there the whole time
that premise yeah you know how many
comedians there are hundreds
and none of us have gone it's only one
good nacho
and then a desert of dried chips
and song on the bottom
ham it's not fair give it to me
it might be on tim robinson's show i
mean that's it all right
uh it's adjacent i made it better
[Laughter]
um it's been six years since mad men who
do you miss the least
i'm canceled for that you pete
[Laughter]
you're talking to pete campbell
the character pete campbell who don
draper dick whitman famously didn't like
oh i'm sorry too political
i thought you might say don draper no
but like you know it was it has i can't
believe it's six years it was 15 years
since the pilot aired which was weird
somebody sent me that um but uh we lost
bobby moore's uh this last couple of
weeks and uh he was such a bright light
and an amazing man an amazing career um
and i i
was very sad to see him go but i didn't
miss him the least i just wanted to give
him yeah no that's a beautiful use of my
terrible question you can give that up
yeah
are you a weed guy weed no i mean i'm
not against it i'm all for folks
it just doesn't
i don't know if it doesn't work on me
like i tend to just go out to sleep
which is not the worst thing but it's
kind of like oh are we going to sleep
like well then cool let's
have some weed and it's like this is
really
ham on the right i've had i had the one
once i had it once
where it was uh it made me laugh and i
had the greatest time yeah i've never
ever had that again oh no right to sleep
you chased the dragon
not really i was like i don't think it's
i don't think it's for me no he doesn't
i chase the dragon because i've had one
like silly silly fun time and then every
other time is me eating we were watching
in a bathroom
eating peanut butter in the bathroom
looking in the mirror going like
[Laughter]
this will be me
like
yeah we were watching the dog whisperer
whatever that guy caesar million and
it's for whatever reason it was caesar
milan milan it was which is portuguese
for him actually
it was very funny it was a funny show
yeah funny people
to watch when you're stoned that's
fantastic the best show once just a pro
tip family double dare
family double dare yeah yeah because
kids today know how to be on camera not
then not in the 80s they're like half in
half out the light they have like
unibomber glasses they're like we came
in from orlando
and they like just pee down the khakis
they throw up dry alphabet cereal
there's another version of that which is
watching the very early family feuds
when the families are not chosen for
their telegenic-ness that's right and
you're lying
it's the watson family you're like oh
[Laughter]
this feels real this is i don't want to
be on that ride home no
um all right real quick on amazon do
your favorites
this is my last question for you him
well i have two questions uh real quick
um three i have three questions for you
do you ever get out of the shower uh and
realize you washed your butt but you
forgot to rinse it
sure like you've gotten back in yeah for
sure you go i've gone back in for many
reasons yeah yeah yeah
uh you know like i some for my shower
comes down like from the top like yeah
like 180 whatever 90 degree whatever
that thing is like it's been an angle
yeah it has a top down moves it's a rain
shower
yeah
rain
or a splash splash yeah yeah i've
definitely had that and i'd be like
i didn't yeah you get out of your butt's
a little slippery yeah
no one wants a soapy armpit um
dead over
dead over do you think when we die it's
over yes
all right sorry guys i'm i don't think
it i know it so
uh spend it while you got it
[Laughter]
thanks for that uh it's a bummer
you got a cheers over there somebody
lifted their glass to you yeah i think
it's death himself
[Laughter]
it's that you're a fan of my work
it is quite final you'll find
now prove you can dance
here's the last question um
what's the hardest time you've ever left
the time you've laughed the hardest i i
will say
i will say that it was the the dog
whisperer thing was pretty close yeah uh
the fun it wasn't me but i will say i
laughed pretty hard during this
the the biggest laugh i've ever seen and
i and i've i've heard this phrase of
like rolling in the aisles and you're
like okay i guess that's like that was
that was a fun like 30s term from
broadway when i had them rolling in the
aisles
uh tell people talk then yeah i'm down
my doll split her dress all the way up
again hope this hope this uh world war
two thing works itself out we'll see i
don't know there was two cabbage
fistfuls full of dollars
look i'm here to yes and i don't have it
yet uh
anyways
we
were i was i was at opening weekend of
the second austin powers and the first
one kind of was a stealth hit people
didn't know what to expect yeah they
didn't know what this was going to be
and it was a huge phenomenon lo and
behold it was shag
and then they and then they did a second
one and and so we're here we are i
forget who was in it it was a you know
bigger louder and whatever and uh
there's a reveal on it where uh tom
cruise is actually playing austin powers
he's climbing a thing it's like mission
impossible and he's in the in the blue
suit with a floofy collar and he turns
around and goes yeah baby yeah and the
whole place this is opening weekend
we're in a double decker stadium
theater
at uh at 68th and broadway in new york
city a man and those are those weird
chairs that they don't make anymore that
like kind of squeak back like a little
like yeah
you're like oh this is more comfortable
like i got another inch great
they're loud they're annoying and i
watched this man and heavyset gentlemen
laugh and do this
in front of him almost hit his head on
that and realize he didn't hit his head
and hit the back thing which then breaks
and he falls
out into the aisle laughing
he kept laughing he kept laughing it was
funny he realized that not only was that
funny this was funny and we were
laughing
ah
they're rolling in the aisles it's
actually happening oh
oh my god
and that man was tom cruise watching his
own
the faster from tropic thunder
[Laughter]
give it up for john
john ham john
john him thanks buddy
[Applause]
he said inches he said inches
all right i got the ham afterglow
everybody i'm happy from him
um but there's there's so much more
after this word from me andy's i'm just
kidding um
are you guys excited for this next guest
[Applause]
what was that nine percent of you you
guys excited for this next guest
you know from snl from the movie pop
star give it up for chris redd
chris red
[Music]
what's up man what's going on man what
the [__] is this
great question man
what the [__]
is this do you mean the show or reality
man i'm [__] up man i'm just trying to
figure out
no i flew i flew in today and i got fly
out to miles and nothing is real you you
ever have life feel like you're on
shrooms
yes you know what i'm saying it's like
well you know shroom's instructions just
like like when you buy shrooms like go
to the forest
it's like if you took shrooms and it was
like i'm gonna go to a basketball game
and i'm gonna sit courtside and i'm
gonna be like a [__] pass
it's like that that's how i feel right
now that's really how you feel yeah why
because you were flying also i was
drinking a lot
i'm sleep deprived and i've been
drinking a lot you know and i called my
mom and she was like i don't got a son
no more and i'm like what she didn't oh
today dude no no no no really please
don't make it over dramatic she's a
black mom
she's just she's just doing that because
i'm not in mississippi [__] no one
wants to be in mississippi like by
choice oh
so you s you called your mom on mother's
day and what did she say exactly she was
like oh there he is i don't get a son no
more like [__] it's four o'clock oh
no it's still mother's day
congratulations dude we just my mom was
just here
real mom we i hugged her it was the end
of the meal it was the last 10 seconds
of the last meal we were almost done how
many meals you got three days of three
meals man
it was like oz fest oh my god so much
food and i hug her and i go mom thanks
for being such a great mom and in the
hug she goes i wish you would be a
better son
damn
and there's no sun's day how about that
[__] yeah right there's no sun's day
anywhere man i never bought that [__]
when they were like every day is kids
day [__] you no
no how how's the kid's date i'm grounded
my mom took all my doors and my pants
one time
like what the [__] did you do as a child
with no pants and no door
she took your doors
like all my doors and my pairs of pants
your doers blended scotch whiskey
no no no no i was a child i ain't no
nothing but alcohol doors as in knobs
knock
no the pants were more dramatic than the
doors yeah no i was playing nintendo
like winnie the pooh [__]
[Laughter]
no
why did she take your doors
because i got some bob vila [__] right
there well cause she said don't watch tv
and i was like
challenge accepted
and i closed my door and i locked it and
she was like oh you locked doors
so then she took the door so i could no
longer lock it would she like
busted in like the kool-aid woman no no
she hired a dude to hold a screw oh
another adult involved yeah she brought
she brought my uncle clint he was like
his [__] you should have been [__] up
as he he's talking [__] and he's taking
my door
he don't live there dawg like at all
you know should have been talking [__]
shut up you do crack sometimes
no he did no uncle clint this is a it's
a podcast it'll be out there
[__]
a dude sometimes smoked crack yeah oh he
was he prided himself on sometimes being
cracking
he said no i ain't a full crackhead i'm
i you know half moon [__] what
half you can't say half moon and just do
crack half moon
i don't even know what that means dog
but i kind of get it yeah he's like a
horoscope for crackheads
he's a gemini for crap
he was a half-head he was a half-head he
was a half-header he was oh he's gonna
love the fact you said that
don't you wanna i'm gonna go back to
somewhere i'm gonna see him like yeah
you you know your boy a half-head shut
the [__] up
is he still on that crack nah
okay good
i am dead
and he took the door off and then how
long did you not have doors oh for like
a week or two
did that overlap with not having any
pants
no no the pants came back around school
time so monday
the pants were back people were like oh
pants are back
what was the idea of taking your pants
i think my mom was just mad
she was like you and also you can't have
pants
it was like me and my little brother
like what and my little brother you know
he's a little brother she's like i got
pants
putting on different pants around me
like what the [__] are you doing dog
we're on the same team
what the [__] is going on that's how i
feel about half head he's on your team
yeah who gets a call from a mom and it's
like i'm gonna take my son's doors and
he's like i'll be there in five i'm
smoking some crack right now but i'll be
there uh if you know anything about
crackheads looking for the next job
she paid him
yeah
she
i thought this was like a family affair
it's like i need some free family affair
she could she could give her money but
that would go against you know what she
what she stands for which i'm not going
to give you money for credit you got to
work
you have to work for yourself to work
for yeah yeah and also she called a lot
of people and nobody was ridiculous
enough to take a door off their son's
hinges
except my crackhead ass uncle clint
that's when it's good today i'll take
the [__] doors off [__] what
else doors you need taking off no other
doors he's removing faucets it's for
free i took the faucets out for
breakfast that toilet outside the
bathroom i put this in the fender room
now you can sit near your couch
it's half head
what's up with your mom
is she religious yeah she what flavor um
man every every black flavor uh baptist
methodist method methodist episcopal
uh
yeah what's going on there why did you
keep changing teams there's a lot of
genres of jesus dog you know what i'm
saying there's a lot of numbers yeah
there's a lot of genres of jesus oh
gyras genres yeah genres yeah you have
you have a long look i i'm here you need
more black friends
all you hearing is a black chicago
accent for real i couldn't i couldn't
hear him either ham also didn't have
good mic technique
pam you are not loved right now
keep going
yeah no we we
genre jesus genre yeah there's a lot of
genres of jesus you find out that most
of the genres uh are similar
yeah
no [__] mormon jesus christ
hey i don't know how you white people
let that [__] happen [__]
have you read that book it's like
cartoon care which is an alien
movies [__]
it's also jesus comes to america no
offense to my latter-day saint friends
but jesus does come to america and that
yeah and that's crazy dude
you telling me jesus was hated i were
prostitutes and other people it was
walking on water i was like hey dawg we
gotta go to america
which didn't exist yet no at all it was
native
what's america trust me
you trust me about that half a crack
didn't you
stupid god
john 14 6 other sheep
so you memorized the shortest
[__] verse in a [__] fake
bible
good job man what else did you do today
put on pants
this [__]
this [__] hey this [__] here
look at this [__] here i didn't
know i've always wanted to conspire with
you
i love that's my favorite part of this
[__]
this is it see this is why this is
better than stand-up if i was doing
stand-up a guy like that it's like a
curtain is on fire in your living room
and everyone's just like pretending that
they don't see it it's like it's fine
every once in a while you smell smoke
but it's mostly fine
but like when you're doing stand up
you're like doing a routine here you can
be like what the [__] this is why i love
this this is my stand up though you
understand i mean i would talk about
this [__] for 35 minutes if
we're in a different setup there's a
[__]
t-table in this [__] you know what i'm
saying
this chairs [__] i'm trying to act like
i'm in a library what is happening
i thought he had no no he's good he's
good you should let him oh are you
asking me to boot him
35 minutes
cody oh nick
huh oh give you a are you the guy why
are you the guy that was sitting
oh you're standing up now [__] sit the
[__] down man look at that why are you
dressed like the help [__] sit down
[Applause]
no he's not like he'll give you more
popcorn in a movie theater
sit your ass down
you look like you were in greece as an
extra
oh my god it's a half hand he's a hat
for sure please sit down there's not
that many white crackheads but you made
the cut
so your mom has different genres of
jesus yeah my mom and my dad yeah
we just moved around a lot so we went to
a lot of different churches and whatever
the church's like
dynamic was we just fell in line with it
did you fall in line with it like did
you yeah because as a kid you don't have
a choice for real you can't be like no
i'm not going to church because then
enough people are going to hit you and
you're going to be like i guess i'm
going to church
but did you believe it yeah yeah i mean
i still believe there's something bigger
than us yeah right but i just think all
like like religion is it's too much
money and too much like human influence
you know it's
i think a little muddy you know this is
corny but i think jesus would agree with
you that was the whole temple turning
over the tables thing yeah like as soon
as you turn it into a business it gets
it it gets muddy man i just think he was
a cool dude with long hair i hate the
sandals but you know it is what it is
no sandals suck finish the shoe
how about that [__] finish the shoe how
about that
oh no finish the [__] shoe
i'm sorry you are so [__] funny i'm
really i know i shouldn't interrupt the
flow but like i feel like i'm getting
more talented just by being near you i'm
really enjoying it
what does your mom think of your
devilish ways
damn you sounded like my mom's friend
yo you understand my mom's friend
rebecca was like i'm so what are you
dude when i started comedy my mom's
friend roberta who has the gift of
prophecy you guys know roberta
she wrote me a letter that was like you
shouldn't do stand-up because it's in
bars where there's alcohol and there are
all these verses from exodus you know
it's a stretch when you've got to go
back to exodus yeah yeah exodus was not
a great version of you know what should
make an exodus from the bible the book
of exodus
leviticus get out of here if you're
quoting numbers you're trying to prove
something exactly
and you also don't know numbers right
[Laughter]
all right
no no that was one of those that was a
that was a yeah i knew it was bad when i
said i didn't think it was bad what you
saw was me go in the sand bucket and i
was like something about roman numerals
and i was like maybe i'll just say yes
so that's all you saw so what is what
what does like for real though what does
your mom make of this this is crazy your
life is crazy yeah well she wasn't she
wasn't my fat we didn't get along
growing up but uh once this started
making some money
my mom was like oh
that's what she was trying to say the
whole time so yeah so there's a lot of
resentment there but free from you from
me i wasn't that cute when i didn't have
no loot that sort of thing yeah 100 yeah
you went there with me shooting in the
gym she was like i'm gonna [__] and then
[Laughter]
but when i when i when i started therapy
and i came back i was like i have a lot
of resentment for y'all and i needed we
didn't you confronted them i did yeah oh
i'm a very in your face [__]
this is not staged [__] this is who i
would be
if i was standing outside
like look what it
this is great y'all look like two white
people that saw a black person interact
for the first time
look at this
oh my god i completely agree that's just
totally fair we kind of look the same
it's gotta be strong
this has got to be so
that is the angle but it's not i know
black people that aren't like that you
know anything that don't confront their
mom and say no it's a heart of therapy
and stuff that's crazy i did it
selflessly because i need it too you
know what i mean and but also just like
if we're going to have a relationship i
just couldn't
pretend i don't pretend it was more
loving to confront yeah and they were
like so understanding that they almost
pissed me off
even more no it did i was like i was
like yo i'm gonna talk to y'all y'all
were wrong
you're gonna answer for some [__]
they're like we're here for you whatever
you need i'm like
[Laughter]
what
i was so mad bro i was mad oh they
extinguished it quickly with love yeah
oh i hated it i was like i did i love
y'all too then what the [__] just
happened
but you're i saw your mom on the
mother's day yeah so she's been yeah oh
she's what was she like on the stage
oh she's a natural and i i really yeah
she's very she's like a talented lady
comfortable no she's very talented she's
very comfortable and like on a stage
she's funny when she's not trying too
hard
like she's truly naturally funny she
tries too hard it's like come on
you know but she's like she's like
naturally knows how to like do the thing
and even more now because she's like
watching it all the time and is she able
to see you like if she watches you in a
sketch does she
process it this is a loaded question
because i can watch my mom watch me do
stand-up or a show i was on she won't
hear it it's i think the whole time it's
just
that's my boys
like i've seen them in the audience and
they're just like
and they look around they go yeah
[Laughter]
oh i'm like talking about them and they
still don't understand but does your mom
like oh mama mama
mama watches she's into it she's in it
when i mention how long my parents been
together she looks around and see people
clap oh
okay
and and then if i if i if i like tell a
story or you know you know have like a
narrative joke and uh and you know i've
written a joke about it and something's
like not true she'll almost want to
stand up like i want to get up there and
tell them exactly what happened like no
one gives a [__] man
this is how i get you back you got to
put me in my room for 12 days i get to
make up [__] [__] that's what i get
to do do you keep looking at her and go
man
you shouldn't take me
um look i'm going to ask you a bunch
more questions but let's do it with the
next guest do you know who the next
guest is you know what of course will
you bring them up of course all right
here it is oh please you can get it
where you are please give it up for the
ultimate talented [__] from
chicago please give it up for matteo
lady
[Applause]
right now jeez louise
i have never seen you sleepless why are
you ever sleeped um
hey
no big deal come on
hey what's up hi
nice to see you man good to see you too
i almost didn't make it because i just
had in my mind i'm like you're at the
largo so i'm like listening to mariah on
my way there and then i get there i'm
like boy it's all locked up there must
be some way in and like not getting it
like why would the audience go in and
then they would lock the audit like none
of it
there was like a like a weird like smoke
shop next door like i guess i could get
poppers i mean i don't know i just
so
anyways i made it so i'm so glad you
made it it's wonderful to be here i want
to ask both i have so many questions for
you specifically mateo but i was like i
have the general questions i want to ask
both of you so that's how we'll open
okay who what either one of you can go
first whoever thinks of it first top or
bottom are you at top or a bottom
top all day yeah
but she rides it so i like the bottom
too because i like to see her have fun i
don't know
i will teach you about the bees and the
bees later um the bees and the bees
i used it wrong
i love you i never realized the bees are
the dudes no matteo teaches me all
things gay me
18 we're starting easy so i'm just we're
going over mariah's discography and then
is that real i was like damn i didn't
know my i know mariah was so you know
detrimental yeah mariah was detrimental
yeah to the white community oh she
doesn't like gay people no no she loves
gaming
she's even like which is important
detrimental doesn't mean important [__]
i went to community college yeah i've
been using detrimental raw for a long
time
you understand
i'm glad that we have the moment yeah
you realize listen you have a lot of
people that don't keep it real enough to
say oh hey i keep it real i'm wearing
traffic on my t-shirt right now
hey bro listen i didn't know what
detrimental meant but i did [__] my
college teacher so ah
i feel like i wanted some way you did
yeah no i don't know maybe it's all
trauma
it's here 23. it's real early for these
kind of
revelations is that the right word yes
[__] man
you taught me it's more loving to
confront yeah right yeah it is
stupid
have you either
[Laughter]
have you ever let it go shut the [__] up
man yeah your hairline is hanging on by
a thread my [__] why is he yelling i
don't understand because he has a big
forehead
is he a part of the show or just wants
so much attention no he's waiting on his
meth pickup oh my god gross what an
idiot
this is chicago right here yeah yeah
that's really great hilarious
has anything ever happened to you that
you can't explain psychics ghosts ufos
anything uh how i got fired from
michaels
you are the king
well i know how i was stealing but um
actually
stealing this is real chicago i had all
my friends come in and steal too yeah oh
that's how you knew he was really
winning you was really winning if you
could get your friends and you'll come
up here around 12 o'clock dawg i was
like just show up i'm like the security
cameras aren't there just show up i'll
swipe your id and go home you know like
so funny yeah mike then i got fired from
the container store because i was also
stealing and um
i stole them from every job what were
you stealing from the container store um
okay so there were these okay
there were these little tiny containers
you could so i'm i love playing game boy
and there were things you anyway it's
really cute to put your game boy game
stuff in it
and i i love pokemon anyway so i just
stole that and then this [__] of a
woman named linda who used to eat
starbursts out of a chex box fired me
and i was like get your life together
linda
[__] [__]
yo i need to know more about linda dawg
like did she did she drop the starburst
in the chex box
did she eat the chicks it was like yo
i got another this isn't over
[Laughter]
i can't say goodbye to this boy did she
just starburst already come in a
container she wanted people to think she
was eating checks like like i'm having a
healthy snack [__] it's all the
strawberries
i see you yeah we can see your mouth
[__] yeah i know what chex mix looks
like when you chew it
both of those chex mix must be real
stale
have you ever seen a ghost
no i ghosts don't exist but my aunt so
i'm italian and mexican so that means is
anyone italian or mexican here i feel
like
how many how many uh uh ants do you have
to talk to dead people
[Laughter]
this is only if you have any answers to
talk to dead people
yeah yeah it's a normal thing for
latinos and italians they all by ain't
naked that's what i was gonna say like
your heritage is a ghosty people you're
not really sleepy
you're not into it you just call me ugly
how dare you i'm not fired from
michael's yeah
no i don't believe in ghosts but my aunt
nicki really does believe in ghosts but
and she talks to them well that's what
she says right i don't know i love my
aunt nikki but they also do this thing
they put this thing over your wrist and
if it swings a certain way it tells you
how many kids you're going to have mine
just swung and called me a [__] i mean
it's like
you know it's pretty
now i i believe in your stress
i believe that's [__] it i believe in
ghosts but uh but like every time i've
been haunted it's by a ghost that's kind
of like unbothered and i don't like that
like i'll hear some [__] in the other
room i'm like oh [__] a ghost this [__]
takes a long time
to haunt me bro and i'm like hey bro
what are you watching tv
what else do you have going on yeah my
tv would turn on and turn off that was
the only thing that was weird happening
and i'm like [__] this nigga's watching
tv
oh you know what i love ghost adventures
it's my favorite tv show it's been going
on for 20 seasons like they've never
found a single ghost and
the host is a complete nightmare his
name is zach he looks like trash and he
says every episode is like why are you
zach i'm a demonologist
first of all my parents were
disappointed when i told them i was gay
i can't imagine
i'm a d
sitting them down
and being like mom dad i'm going into
demonology
they'd be like we'd rather you suck a
dick i mean it's like
at least it's there but also
i yes
i would like you know
also you know so because the travel
channel's only ghost hunting shows and
it's a lot of white people only white
people look for ghosts by the way only
hey i i wanted to do that i wanted to
make a first black
it's called the it's called they just
assume it's five black barbers it gets
worse and no
it's called ghost brothers no see i
don't need to make all that i want to
make a ghost show called we good yeah
yeah
where you never go in hey yo we go we go
right up to the door like yo hey yo this
is man haunted
ah we good
wait kristen i'm gonna do a show called
queer eye for the dead guy yeah
and
[Applause]
it'll just be five gay men walking into
a haunted well of course he's haunting
you look at you're wearing it you know
like
[Laughter]
and
and the ghost won't want to leave
because they'll make the house look even
nicer than when it went before
oh we should go and why don't we have
our own tv netflix call us yeah netflix
we're available
i just want to watch this all i know i
this is a day off for old people we were
on a plane together and do you know how
annoyed all the rich white men were
hearing us talk all day this is the two
worst things a republican can fly
with is a black man and a gay man having
a good time
in first class
and also wait the guy in front of you
hated us he kept doing that thing like
he was watching fox also
now keep in mind so chris said the
funniest thing to me because we're like
we're starving it's so early it was like
nine o'clock in the morning
and so we get we're like well there'll
be a meal there's always a meal so we
sit down they're like okay for your meal
for your meal today either a greek salad
or pastrami and kristen out loud at nine
o'clock in the morning
yo when i tell you they gave me a
sandwich with the wettest bread
this bread was wet my [__] like it took
a shower and got on lettuce
do you understand
finish the shoe
[Applause]
mine was a single piece of dead lettuce
i
of course the gay went for the salad but
it was terrible it was like a brownie
with a salad and i was like what is this
a death man we bonded over a great
british bake off we just did a show
together that's awesome we're all so
obsessed obsessed
who has time to say yeah i love bbbo yes
arthur we get mad when we watch it
though we're like if you're if you're
not eating cake and you're watching
people eating cake and they're being
critical about the cake you're like well
their criticisms are very slight you
know what i mean they're not like it's
not like america where they're like you
know what was that gordon ramsay like
what the [__] is this your family's
gonna die you know like it's like it's
more like you know like it's just very
disappointing and then it's like some
old woman in her early hundreds like bye
just like buy some tree and she's like i
can't believe i'm crying over a pastry
you know like it's so different
i love oh british bake off is so good
and i love that like they they you can't
understand anything that they're saying
you have to watch it with subtitles
say that woman rosie remember rosie she
was so she was like a vet or something
every time they talked about like okay
rosie what are you making today
somebody don't give me shoulders you're
like sure she said what 20 minutes later
like oh she was making a chicken
bro i don't watch that show but i do
watch is it cake
wait what's that yo so it's a new show
and mikey day uh hosts it and it's and
it's a bunch of people who make cakes
out of things that don't look like cake
so it'll look like a purse but they'll
cut into it and it'll be
and my
okay now i saw something weird
[Laughter]
i watch this [__] with my cousin and he
gets mad
when when everything is cake they don't
look like cake he's like [__] that
ain't cake bro that's a purse
i'm like but it's not dog it's cake like
that's [__] what are these what do
they do with a day
i want to ask a dumb question is it
sometimes not cake
yeah it's sometimes it's just a purse my
[__] that that seems way easier to get
purses
than to get somebody to bake a purse
so you can have lots of things that
aren't cake yeah oh man on netflix it
sounds like there's nothing on the
street right now yeah
you what it sounds like we're on canal
street right now like is that a purse is
that a real person is that a purse how
much is that this one's cake yeah i
would have bought way more purses if i
thought some of them were cake oh yeah
are you kidding me that'd be awesome
sorry peach you have other questions
no what else are you guys thinking about
that's my question what else do you guys
got going on with each other
what else are you gonna say yeah that's
my question i love these questions being
prompted i feel like i'm in a barbara
walters interview
don't tell me the time you laughed the
hardest in your life
the hardest i laughed in my life
i was
playing uh call of duty with my friend
jacob riffs i know jacob and do you know
jacob no chris oh okay
i do that no i don't even know where
your worlds would ever collide
you know what i mean like i wouldn't
know how you two would know each other
we were playing call of duty over the
pandemic and we were i was on twitch and
it call of duty is very straight you
know like fortnight's like the gay
version and so
because you shoot and decorate at the
same time so you know
you're mid battle you're like we need a
bay window but i
but in call of duty we were like we
could like we're giving ourselves pep
talks like jake was like we could do
this mateo we can play with the
straights so we're playing
we start hiding immediately because you
know gays love hiding and like
and and this is one of my bits but it's
true i literally was so scared and
jacob's like frantically looking at the
wall like jacob what is it he's like
this wall people are so cute i could
live here but anyway so
we were we were we were there and and
we were like hiding i have it on video i
could show you we're hiding in our
closets and
[Applause]
we're whispering to each other we don't
need to whisper to each other because we
have headsets on and i'm like jacob
they're coming like
and then a grenade comes in and explodes
and we just it was so pathetic that and
i couldn't stop laughing it was 20
minutes of me like just shaking you know
it's better than sex you're laughing
sorry and jacob's like why are you
laughing i was like because no one in
the 20 year history of this game has
ever looked around i've been like i love
this place we could totally live here
like
you know what i mean like
like we were like in the sound of music
or something like we could turn these
drapes into children's play clothing
like
madness i mean we were i was crying i
couldn't move i screamed like a woman
when i died like i just
i was like ned flynn was like ah you
know like
i was screaming and it was so funny it
was and then also hundreds of people are
watching and it's on twitch god
yeah i'll send you this i have the whole
thing
i'll send it to you guys dropbox baby
that is amazing it really i was dying
yes red
oh man
uh the funniest i've left
it had to be it hadn't been backstage
seven minutes ago yeah for real
uh ninth grade my my friend todd um
oh they did backyard wrestling
and on his trampoline he had in the
backyard
girl and
he decided because like everybody else
was like having like these like big
moments right where they were doing
choke slams and [__] he couldn't he
didn't have no upper body i'm dead
already yeah so he was like i gotta i
gotta show up and show out that's what
he said to me
and i was like what the [__] does that
mean
i'm a child what are you talking about
and and my man showed up 20 minutes
later on the roof
and he was like i'm a leg drive on the
[__] trampoline and all his friends
were like yeah and i was like [__] this
is not good
and then he and he's any like
he jumped off
my man jumped off like this and he flew
there like this and he broke his [__]
because
he you know he landed right where the
metal was dawg
and i was like
and everybody was like no and i was like
and i couldn't stop laughing i couldn't
stop laughing the ambulance came and
they were like who's this black kid
laughing on the ground
and you know and then he went to school
the next day and this is when i laughed
the hardest he went to school the next
day he was like yeah i got in a fight
like [__] no you did
todd you broke your [__] on the
trampoline [__]
chris read matteo late everybody i
couldn't have asked for a better guess
that was incredible thank you so much
guys we got we ran out of time that's
why we gotta go
thank you for being here one more time
for valerie
chris red
mateo lane
oh you gotta say keep it crispy keep it
crispy
keep it crazy
hell yeah keep it crispy everybody good
night
[Music]